hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I'm still here now I
don't know a lot about this game oh ah
finally moving into my new place a
chance to start a new life
the landlord seemed a little weird about
this place but I don't have time to
worry about that I need to finish
putting those books away okay alright
what books are we talking about here the
oh okay oh now I suspected that this was
a type of horror game but it seems
awfully peaceful to be that now I have
to meticulously put books away I mean
I'm down with it don't get me wrong I'm
down with it but I just I didn't know
that this was gonna be the primary part
of the gameplay I have a funny feeling
that it's about to turn horrifying
and/or weird before the end of this
almost done a little more I don't have a
lot what the heck why are my books
moving yeah I had a funny feeling about
this I need to figure out what's going
on I should ask the Internet
guys with all my problems I need to ask
the internet immediately hello wahoo uh
why don't I why don't my boy my parents
wanna talk to me you should try calling
your parents to make sure they aren't
dead well that's sad I guess all right
why don't my bathroom lights work check
the breaker wires one of them might be
loose why don't my stuff's what no my
stuff stay steal all my furniture and
stuff keeps moving around on its own you
got ghosts bro you need to perform an
exorcism oh snap I Oh God
oh I think I have ghosts I'm pretty
hundred percent sure that this might be
the workings of ghosts
oh yeah definitely hosts probably that I
should ask the internet how to get rid
of these ghosts okay I have aa full
lumping armpit there's a good chance you
have an infection you should make sure
you're washing thoroughly and shaving
carefully there's also a likelihood it
could be cancer
huh I have a problem with stuff moving
by itself see I have a ghost I want to
piss off when I want to annoy my sister
I flip the light switch over and over
gets her every time hmm this sounds
promising
I should flip my lights on enough to
annoy the ghosts okay I'll do that I
don't know how I'm gonna do that how
about this hey ghosts
hey ghosts hey get some of this
cut that out dude jeez who said that get
out of my house no way this is my house
stop being such a jerk this is my house
now you must be dead oh wow this is
heavy my spirit must be stuck here
because my body still needs to be put to
rest that makes sense to me will you
help me find my body then oh sure if
it'll get you to leave me alone I think
I need to call the police about this one
if it's a dead body in my apartment that
seems bad I will find your body and put
you to rest okay can i how do I print
screen' using Mac delete my internet
history you can't destroy the laptop if
I know if I'm being haunted keep things
from moving get rid of a ghost alrighty
then yes I need to find the body
hello Oh No hello nope hello hello body
dead body dead body oh hello what was
that I don't know I just did but I think
I can oh okay hello hello oh hey that's
me you found me oh oh you're a fish so
that's how I died wow this is heavy
I got shat out by someone well can you
help me move on so I can stop haunting
this place I'll finally put you to rest
little buddy oh there's like that
episode of Dexter's Laboratory you have
to put him to rest
no you have to flush him I'm free rest
in peace little buddy
I'll always remember you oh that's it
what you go on to have a peaceful night
and live comfortably in your new
apartment but you can never shake the
memory of your little friend you
occasionally take a peek in the toilet
and dream of finding them there again
but all you find in the bowl is
emptiness occasionally there's a screw
and wow what an astonishing game unlike
any I've ever played in my entire life
Oh a masterpiece
what an incredible adventure fun it's so
cool I mean it's weird and it is exactly
like that episode of Dexter's Laboratory
where he didn't flush the fish and it
haunted him to that day and then tried
to suck his sister down into the toilet
but that's all another story so thank
you for joining me on this epic
adventure thank you for helping me put
this fish soul to rest I think we will
all miss Fredman fish but he's resting
now that ghostly ghostly fish is
swimming in the sewers of peace and we
will always remember Fred always so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think in
fact write a full review of this
incredible adventure down in the
comments below
I'll read each and every one of them and
I thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]